superlatives time chris for week 10
what's your first one
vader is not dead death vader lives
in foxborough still i mean i just i
we haven't really i know we hit on the
little death vader
i might have said not yeah it's darth
vader i might have said death vader i
don't know it's early in the morning and
you know i might have said that yes but
they're not dead
darth vader is what i want to say all
right and i mean
that first off it just how could we be
new england's unbelievable they really
are i mean
nobody gave them a chance last night big
bad baltimore
i mean the the patriots defense it's
been a little bit all over the place
i mean you don't know how good they can
be but
no stefan gilmore to bottle up that
attack by lamar
jackson and company i mean their
inability to
you know run the ball and dominate the
game that way that was really impressive
i mean it just speaks to bill
belichick his son as well the great
things they do on the defensive side of
the ball
it just shows you that you know cobin 19
and all those things how great of a
coach bill
is i mean he's their greatest asset here
they are
you know back in the building a lot and
i mean really they've played
three pretty perfect games in a row
they're not that talented
but buffalo they're driving to win cam
fumbles yeah
okay they played it perfect though
coached it perfect
cam played it perfect last week against
the jets kind of the same thing yeah
they lit up some big plays in the pass
game not enough burnham in the jets game
but still it was coach perfect cam
newton played it perfect and again that
happened again last night
they have no room for error but they
seem to make it happen and
you know just the physicality in which
they played you know they weren't sloppy
you know other baltimore were seeing
snaps go all over the place the
interception by lamar jackson before the
start of the first uh end of the first
half that was a huge moment
uh i just got to give credit to new
england when we count them out they're
just never dead they're unreal
you know our power rodney harrison a
patriots hall of famer was giving me a
hard time within the past week or so
on this idea that i keep pushing that
the best teams in the afc
do not want to see the patriots in the
playoffs and ronnie's argument is oh the
patriots aren't any good they're only
good it's like yeah but if they
if they get to the point where they're
good enough to qualify
they're going to be held a lot better
than they are now that's my point if
they find a way
to fix this on the fly right if they
find a way to win enough games to take
that
seventh seed you'd much rat all due
respect to the browns
if you're the chiefs the steelers
the bills the ravens
you want the browns not the patriots
to come waltzing into your building in
january i would
all due respect to the browns right you
don't want bill belichick in a single
elimination setting because
here's here's a reality he was in a
single elimination setting as a
practical matter last night yeah he was
in a single elimination setting last
monday night
that they could be the team this year
because there's always one of them and
they're never in this posture because
they're always great
they could be that team that finds
themselves in playoff
mode around thanksgiving and just has to
win and win and win
and win because they know if they don't
that's it
and so by the time you get to playoff
mode and you've been
in it when you get to the real playoffs
and you've been playing for your season
every week for six weeks
you've got the mindset the battle test
you want to get and you're going against
a team that's like you know they've had
it easier
and uh they've never they've never had
their backs against the wall and that's
why we see these upsets from time to
time in the postseason
because you've got a team that that is
in mid-season
form if yeah that makes any sense no
that does make sense you're right
i mean hey we've seen the patriots do
that they started off their dynasty
doing that kind of thing whereas
you know brady they were five and five
they were 500 five and five
right they had a fight for life and they
every week was a playoff game
and that just continued right to them
winning the super bowl so
uh we'll see where it goes but you see
they have a formula
and they have some elite things they
have i mean you mention it belichick's
elite
the secondary is elite i mean they are
and that was without stefan gilmore last
night
and their offensive line i knew was
really good but i think after what i saw
last night
that it's elite i know coleas campbell
wasn't out there in company
but man i mean they gash them at certain
times you don't see
baltimore get pushed around very often
it really jumps out to you when you see
it
and that this is one of the few times in
the last four or five years where i can
remember
baltimore being dominated at the line of
scrimmage like that
all right first one for me and you know
this is a saying that's more
common in new york but they do say it in
pittsburgh too they pretty much say it
everywhere
and uh i've got your trap right here is
the
award for the pittsburgh steelers so
much for a trap game
uh every time i've picked the steelers
to win
seven times this year the two times i
picked it picked against him i thought
they were ripe
and both times they blew an ohio team
off
the field are you kidding me with ben
roethlisberger gone all week
on the govern 19 reserve list with knees
injury not knee
knees injuries to big ben and with
the bengals having two weeks to get
ready joe burrow
see this is the problem we get smitten
with these guys and i i
a rooting interest creeps in not that
i'm rooting against the steelers i want
joe burrow
to be good i want the bengals to be good
it's a fun story
and i thought they could pull it off and
my god 36 to 10
it was never even close there was a
moment when it was 12 nothing
and the bengals scored it was 12 7 like
oh here we go
maybe we got something here no we didn't
we didn't have anything the steelers
uh the far superior team and if they
played like that every week
we'd have no qualms about saying they're
going to go 16-0
the problem is most weeks they're living
on the edge that's what's amazing
they've gotten to 9-0
with seven of their wins they could have
gone either way
yeah that and and and that will if they
keep doing that keep finding ways to win
these close games
that will serve them well it's nice
every once in a while
to you know put the pedal to the metal
and not have to sweat it out all the way
through to the end of the fourth quarter
yeah well hopefully that cowboys game
taught them something because we we have
at least seen them
put some teams away here as of late to
where we start to go oh
okay here oh man the pittsburgh team
when they're hitting they're looking
good i mean and you know i just can't
say enough about big ben
you know again he just he's playing the
game the right way
week after week that's the thing i think
that jumps out to me more than anything
big ben in the old days he was good for
oh man you know we're controlling the
game and here's a dumb interception
or you know he tried to move around and
hold the ball in the pocket too long and
force the ball down the field and they
were controlling it and now the game's
you know a toss up
we don't know where it's gonna go we
just don't see any of those moments from
big ben this year
he's kind of just like okay so what it's
ugly
yep it's ugly we're hanging in there
it's six
nothing so what i'm not gonna make a
mistake we got a great defense and they
just slowly chip
away until they find out how they want
to attack you
and then we know they got some weapons
at receiver and
uh yeah they were they looked good
yesterday like you said mike and then
yeah i don't think joe burrows seen
quite a defense like that
i know he had a deal with baltimore but
uh
this is you know different in their own
right where they can rush the passer and
do all these crazy things and they
certainly gave burrow in that passing
game
some issues yesterday and and i think
we're close to calling
it in the afc north i know that the
ravens and the steelers play
in 10 days on nbc thanksgiving night
but the ravens have the titans this
weekend
the steelers have the jaguars and when
you look at the rest of the schedule the
steelers do have a game at buffalo but
they they should be able to hold their
edge
over the ravens especially if they beat
the ravens in 10 nights
uh and i'm i've resolved that i am not
picking against the steelers again
the rest of the year i they could lose
every game between now and week 17 i'll
still pick them to win week 17.
uh they they just they have that magic
you know we look for the team of destiny
every year and i think there's only one
team right now that stands out with that
label
and it's like people don't want to
accept it i don't know why because they
don't have
you know they don't have the great
all-time goat quarterback like tom brady
and they don't have the shiny new toy
yes you know like a kyler murray
and we take everything for granted that
they're doing um but but i think they're
the team right now that you have to look
at what team stands out is the most
special team right now it's them
i i i don't disagree with that i think
you're right there i mean if there's one
team that stands above the rest i'm
gonna put them there
you know just slightly above kansas city
as far as having that special mojo
but yeah they've had a little bit more
of a mojo to them this year certainly
and they got a little magic and
seemed to have great self-belief and
just it all going in the right direction
so i agree with you there there's no
doubt um
what do you want to see give me your
give me your preferred right now afc and
nfc
championship game what are your
preferred games right now
i think obviously steelers chiefs in the
afc can we agree on that
yes i'd want to see steelers chiefs i
got no yep agreed there
and then in the nfc oh man i don't even
know the nfc's brutal
brutal because i'd love to see brees and
brady
right that would be great i'd love to
see any of them versus aaron rodgers
i'd love to see any of them versus
russell wilson i'd love to see any of
them verse kyler mary it's very
confusing i don't know where to go there
i think really listen in my heart of
hearts you know me
i want to see aaron rodgers and russell
wilson that's what i want to see as much
as i love brady
and the breeze and the story there i
guess if you're going to ask me right
now in november i don't know what day it
is
i'm going to go with that one 16th by
the way 16th it's okay
um i i you know
i i think kyle murray and russell wilson
would be the most compelling even though
we're going to see it
i know that's right thursday i have a
feeling after we see it again thursday
we're going to be saying
we want one more uh or saints bucks
would be great but it would be
to see kyler against tom brady i mean
talk about the ultimate contrast
in style and everything but yeah there's
a bunch of different permutations in the
nfc
that i wouldn't complain about but boy
we really want
steelers chiefs you know and think about
that folks when you're rooting for
upsets in the divisional round we like
chaos but the aftermath of chaos is we
get
robbed of a potentially great
championship game let's not go overboard
rooting for chaos in the divisional
round i think we really want steelers
chiefs
to find a way to get together all right
chris what's your next superlative uh
meme this
okay how about meme this that's what
daniel jones said to everybody in
philadelphia and new york
after yesterday i mean he'd see that
would've worked better i got your meme
right here
i got you you're right hey i got your
meme right here hey philadelphia go back
to philadelphia okay i got your meme
right here i'm gonna run it in this time
i'm not gonna trip at the 10. okay
forget about it
i mean yeah hey great payback for the
new york giants blowing that game
against philadelphia a few weeks ago it
was there to be had they had a 21-10
lead
i mean you know like i said about bill
belichick and everything like that
the one thing i respect about the giants
and it's that doesn't
look pretty but their approach to the
game on a week in week out basis
is correct to where i always go i
understand what they're doing
joe judge has a cohesive game plan here
i think that's something to be excited
about
as a new york giants football football
fan at least it is for me
but don daniel jones i mean some big
throws
but the running that was really what put
them over the top
you know the touchdown a few plays here
and there where he kept it around the
edge
and in a game where hey yeah we all
thought philly would
win and find some way to ugly you know
ugly
pull it off like they usually do that
just didn't happen
and that was because of daniel jones and
it was because of the giants defense too
man is the eagles offense and
embarrassment they really are i don't
know what else to say
and and here's what amazes me about the
eagles yesterday
doug peterson is an andy reed disciple
and one of andy reid's greatest traits
is if you give him extra time to prepare
for a team
he will win yeah for doug peterson to
have an extra week to get ready for the
giants i mean this wasn't
the giants this is in the giants what
have they been
you know it's not like you're taking on
a great opponent and did not
have it going was uh was stunning here's
doug peterson after
the loss taking full blame for what
happened
it's on me you know that we play play
the way we did today
you know quite honestly um but i felt
the energy was was good
it's you know it is it's difficult
obviously with without the fans but uh
that's
both teams have to deal with it and um
you know can't make excuses for it
i i was watching nfl network last night
and
there was the question posed on the
screen is doug peterson's job in
jeopardy and
i thought was it really is it i
could it be the guy just won a super
bowl three years ago and
jeffrey lurie's approach has been now he
hasn't fired many coaches
but after a second straight season of no
playoffs
you're out well peterson's been to the
playoffs the last three years yeah
so i i can't imagine he'd be in any type
of jeopardy but
well you got some some very anxious and
nervous and hostile eagles fans
and you have to wonder what he needs to
do to avoid being on the hot seat next
year i think that's really the issue
if this keeps up next year he and maybe
mike zimmer if the vikings don't
continue what they've done the past
couple of weeks
are going to be at the top of the list
of the guys that that
really are under fire yeah i i mean i i
think that would be
uh certainly a possible scenario i think
it's crazy to talk about him being on
the hot seat yet i mean you're right i
mean come on
super bowl playoffs injuries
still going to the playoffs i mean that
team they brought to the playoffs last
year
you know doug peterson and carson wentz
that i mean
that was nothing special they did that
out of you know toughness
coaching willpower and just being gritty
that way um but
there are concerns and it's just it's
always something every week
you know it really is it's just you know
oh man this week the defense list is
down this week it's carson wentz and
turnovers this week we can't run the
football
this week we can't get a pass completion
over 10 yards everyone is five yards i
mean
uh it's just there's nothing pretty
nothing to hang your hat on especially
the offensive side of the ball
and that's where it's disappointing
because they were a little healthy
yesterday
miles sanders was back alshon jeffrey
was back
jalen rieger's there and to still put up
that performance and go over
nine on third down against the new york
giants
with no great pass rushers and things
like that i mean that to me
uh is shocking shockingly bad and uh
yeah they got issues and and they still
yeah the way the giants are playing
maybe the giants are going to catch them
but they're still in first place in the
worst division in football 10 26
and 1 is the combined record of the nfc
east with only two wins
outside of the division for the entire
year
all right i'm struggling with the next
one i'm trying to come up with a label
that encapsulates the idea
that the raiders have gone to a place
where
everything is glitz and glamour
and the raiders all of a sudden are
ground and pounds yeah seriously
right i mean they went to the wrong city
right uh so uh the the we'll call it the
ground and pound award
uh the misplaced ground and pound award
because you know you need to move to
to cleveland or somewhere i mean this is
not a las vegas thing
but yesterday josh jacobs yet again the
heart and soul of the offense 21 carries
for 112 yards two touchdowns devante
booker
remember him second round pick of the
broncos i thought he was long gone
16 carries 81 yards two touchdowns
rushing
derek carr had 154 passing yards on 25
attempts
the defense was awesome the raiders are
six and three
watch out for them chris yeah i mean the
raiders with that running attack and
their offensive line
you know they can dominate games that
way to where they don't have to take a
lot of chances in the past game they
control the clock their defense is not
super talented
but with them staying off the field and
fresh that gives them a great advantage
that way too
groot it's one of greatest gruden's
greatest assets it always has been
he'll always be famous for throwing the
ball and rich gannon and everything like
that but even in those days
he ran the ball when we were in tampa we
always used to talk about pounding the
rock
pound the rock he is gonna run the ball
because he's gonna
establish some physicality he's gonna
back a defense off from blitzing and
doing things like that and most of all
the way his team is built it's built
around their own line that's a big win
they're a tough football team
they might not be the most talented team
in the in the league but they're tough
week in and week out i give john gruden
a lot of credit there
that was a dominant butt whooping they
gave the broncos yesterday
that average broncos defense real
average i don't know what you're talking
about what are you talking about well
because
they made a whole like video of me
calling oh okay
yeah i thought yeah it's funny i'm
having fun they picked off drew locke as
you may have mentioned four times and uh
the right we have to give the raiders
the respect that they are due
and and they're hey sunday night
when kansas city comes to town i know
the chief said this is andy reid two
weeks to get ready
and and borrow as i said earlier we're
all gonna end up picking the chiefs i
can't write the raiders off maybe i'll
take the short straw this week
and take the raiders while everybody
else takes the chiefs and of course
that'll be the week that the the chiefs
ultimately win all right give me another
one
oh i forgot it was my turn there hold on
a second you have another one yeah i
have another one not one off from the
top of my head so hold on a second let
me think of one here oh
i want i do have one off the top of my
head well i want to do some of the a
little bit you just said
the two-headed monster award for those
two in cleveland you know you just
talked about the two running backs and
the raiders but the same thing in
cleveland
i mean that day yesterday holy weather
i mean that was unreal there in
cleveland but
thank god they got a run game to rely on
and thank god they got
two just absolute starting superstar
running backs
i mean it's getting to the point
yesterday where
you i can't tell which one's which i i
really can't
they're both got legs and butts that
can't fit in their uniform
and they break tackles and run away from
people but nick chubb and kareem hunt
were amazing yesterday
and really kareem hunt was more amazing
nick chubb just had the big run at the
end of the game he had a real good game
don't get me wrong
but it was a kareem hunt day but nick
chubb got the big highlight where he
stepped out at the end but
man you know that's where the kevin
stefanski coming from minnesota listen i
know i gave cleveland a little crap from
higher and
that's where i'll give you credit their
vision to know wait
we got running backs we got an offensive
line maybe we should bring a
offensive run type head coach here and
that was really smart and they're
reaping the benefits of them
right now and good for cleveland another
six and three team
that you know what hey even in the year
that we've expanded
to seven the afc a good team oh it may
get left out which makes it even harder
for the patriots
right to get a spot at the table which
is to the extreme delight of the
steelers and the chiefs and anyone else
who would cross paths with new england
in the postseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports